[موسيقى]
هذه السنه صمنا باخر الربيع وبعد ثلاث
سنوات نبي نصوم فاخرجته وبعد ست سنوات
بنصوم بعزه شتاء وبعد سبع سنوات نبي نصوم
رمضاننين في سنه واحده في عام 2030 تحتضن
بين دفتيها عام
1451 و 1452
الهجريتين لا تعجبي يا سلمو من رجل ضحك
المشيب براسه فبكى قد كان يضحك في شيبته
واتى المشيب فقلما
ضحكا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ورمضان يطوف على الفصول الاربعه كل 33 سنه
تقريبا ليش لان السنه الهجريه انقص من
السنه الميلاديه ب 11 يوم
تقريبا وصيام رمضانين في سنه واحده يحدث
في السنين الميلاديه دون الهجريه ويتكرر
كل 33 سنه فقد حدث في عام 1965 وفي عام
1997 وسيحدث في عام 2030 ويتكرر حدوثه في
عام 2063 فعام 1451 سيبدا رمضان في 5
يناير عشرين ثلاثين وفي عام
1452 يبدا رمضان في 26 ديسمبر 20 30 بمعنى
ان سنه 20 30 سنصوم فيها 36 يوما 30 يوم
تابعت 51 وسته ايام تابعه ل52 وتسمى السنه
الكريمه اكرم الناس ما بين الورى رجل تقضي
على يده للناس حاجاه لا تقطعن يد المعروف
عن احد ان كنت تقدر فالايام تراك
[موسيقى]